the stunning skyline says it all Dubai
as a city that doesn't hold back its
fabulous wealth has made it famous
around the world
this year borussia dortmund traveled to
the Gulf State for the first time a
training camp under the Arabian Sun let
them escape the cold German winter our
reporters were on hand to see if the
setting was as perfect as they'd
imagined although demon shortest freedom
players are totally thrilled they all
said it would be the best training camp
they'd ever had the only issue is the
evening rush hour traffic that's a bit
problematic I'm effective but when you
think of the climate the sports
facilities the spa the regeneration
possibilities and the choice of hotels
it's not such a big deal its first class
here is absolute lesson but look at the
not I'll save a training center tells a
different tale building work is ongoing
here even as the Dortmund players are
training it doesn't bother them so much
as the fans only 25 are allowed to watch
from the sidelines not many more have
travelled to Dubai though the decision
to hold a training camp here has brought
the club criticism from human rights
organizations as well as fans before
leaving for Dubai we spoke to blogger
daniel matin he's one of many fans whose
question the morality of the move
I was a dog once did for Florence stands
for open mindedness tolerance and
equality and against right-wing
extremism now they're flying off to a
country where human rights simply don't
exist where women homosexuals and
non-muslims have no rights completely
goes against our values of
open-mindedness and tolerance Lord using
the out in red of nitrile or guns
complexity I lived at Dortmund luxurious
hotel the club came to play down the
issue officials say the criticism
levelled at them is over the top CEO Han
cof named hrvatska told us they would
have been criticized wherever they went
I wouldn't I in there with social media
getting bigger all the time you get
criticized for everything these days I
guarantee wherever you go there will
always be someone it will have a problem
with it when they're done kkithika Human
Rights Watch have long been trying to
raise awareness of abuses in Dubai but
hrvatska says the club can't be
restricted by such issues this kind of
kinda and soft about no one can
seriously expect that we won't have any
contact with regimes that in some way
don't comply with our moral values for
the only concession then we'd have to
start getting picky about where we go in
Europe to get selected owned though
these are it's typical for people to get
on their high horses and tell us off
then but I think they should tone it
down a bit soggy finna the Sultan
visible Zumba Singh dismantling palm
luxury and prestige commercials from
dubai's tourist board present the city
as a glamorous travel destination but
the glitz is built on the backs of
exploited workers from India Pakistan
and Nepal we hear that their wages of
around 150 dollars a month are often
paid late and sometimes not at all many
of them also have their passports
confiscated but authorities come down
hard on critics
we want to know more Human Rights Watch
put us in contact with an activist here
it's not easy to convince him to meet
with us eventually he agrees to being
filmed if we keep the location secret
ahmed mansour is one of the few who
speaks out even though interviews like
these can put his life in danger
unfortunately the human rights situation
in UAE is going from bad to worse and it
is 3d at the moment in one of them it is
darkest time throughout history of UAE
sometimes a tweet is enough to land
someone in trouble with the authorities
off camera akma tells us how prisoners
are tortured he himself has been
imprisoned several times and twice he's
been beaten by guards there's absolutely
no freedom exhibition unity not
there is no room at all and whoever does
that does it add a great risk I and
probably will be wondering why do I
speak I I speak because I have been you
know really working on the edge for
quite a long time I was a Mariah
defender I have to do that in the
evening we head to the mac tomb stadium
usually local club al-shabab plays here
but tonight Dortmund and Frankfurt are
gracing the pitch we look on as Dortmund
produced a convincing performance to win
for nill Dortmund fans here have heard
the criticism of their country they see
things very differently that means i
think is like the iphone users industry
people are saying things that simply
aren't true dubai is being compared to
Qatar and Saudi Arabia but it's not like
that here and even if it was so what in
that case maybe people shouldn't live in
Germany because the German government
does business with the Saudis estimate
the Saudi because it's a year and the
laws here in Dubai can't be compared
with those in Qatar Saudi Arabia it's
much better here they have a summer
break and aren't allowed to work outside
in the hottest part of the day that's
just for the sake of the people here but
the testimony we've heard proves that's
not the whole story there's a good
reason Dorfman's training camp has faced
criticism a team photo with the fans
can't hide the fact that for many back
home the club's image has been tarnished
it seems unlikely that Dortmund will
return to do by after this controversy
Oh